in this video I'm going to use words
like eras periods periods and ages to
refer to segments of time in in the
human or in the pre human past and what
I want to clarify right from the get-go
because frankly this is something that's
confused me in the past is that peat
archaeologists will refer to eras
periods and ages in the human past and
they're usually referring to periods of
tens of thousands of years or thousands
of years but these are different eras
periods and ages than the ones that
geologists would refer to when they're
talking about geological time in
geological time era means several
hundred millions of years periods and
ages mean millions of years when a
archaeologists when we're starting when
we're starting the human past this is
just talking they're just generally
talking about long segments of human
time but not in the millions of years
usually in the thousands or the ten
thousands of years so what I want to do
with that out of the way is talk about
what has happened in the the distant
human past or the distant pre-human past
and also touch on some of the classic
classifications for these segments of
time because they they actually tell us
what were the interesting developments
that happened to humanity over over the
two hundred thousand years over the two
hundred thousand years that homo sapiens
have been on this planet or that we
believe that homo sapiens have been on
this planet so the longest period of
time in human past or the category of
human time in there's different ways you
can categorize it is the Paleolithic era
right over here
paleo Paleolithic Paleolithic era and
what really makes that period of time so
this is this begins even in prehistory
or pre human history so before we before
Homo sapiens even existed you have the
beginning of the Paleolithic era that
really began with the development of
stone tools and as we learned in the
video on human evolution there were pre
Homo sapiens species that were using
stone tools and so the Paleolithic era
it's really kind of signified by one the
stone tools but even more that either
either the pre humans or once you know
you go about 200 thousand years ago
humans show up it's it's kind of
distinguished by humans being
hunter-gatherers hunter-gatherers which
essentially means to survive we used to
walk around a lot you know if we
couldn't see something obvious to hunt
maybe maybe a wooly mammoth or something
if we didn't see something obvious to
hunt we would look around for snails or
mushrooms or whatever else and that's
how we would survive that's how we would
live and because we were constantly
adapting to our environment based on the
seasons we were maybe following animals
as they migrated hunter-gatherers were
fundamentally nomadic which essentially
which means that they never settled in
one place for a long time they they were
always ready to kind of pick up probably
their tents and follow the herd or
follow whatever animals they were
hunting or or or or follow the season so
they could go to warmer climates maybe
where there's more likely to to find
something to find on the ground to eat
maybe during the winter who knows and so
the Paleolithic era is really
distinguished by that it's a huge swath
of time in in in human history and it
doesn't come to an end until you get to
the advent of farming so the Paleolithic
era I mean we're literally talking about
over 2 million years ago is when it
starts before Homo sapiens even existed
as a species and it goes all the way to
the advent of harming that we believe
first came about around 11,000 to 7,000
years ago and this abbreviation right
here this BP this does not stand for
british petroleum it stands for before
present or before the present time so
one more acronym to kind of have in your
toolkit when you see things and
obviously if we're 11 thousand years
before the present that's the same thing
as 9 thousand years before Christ or
before the Common Era because Christ was
we believe born 2,000 years ago now it
may or may not be obvious to you but the
advent of Agriculture is a super big
deal arguably the biggest deal and the
development of human civilization or in
all of human history and you might say
you know what's the big deal of
agriculture these these characters over
here look look pretty happy they're able
to walk around a lot they're able to
hunt you know what's the big deal of all
of a sudden people plowing fields and
and domesticating cattle and and having
chickens to lay eggs and whatever else
and the big deal about that besides the
fact that it would change people's diet
is it for the first time it allowed them
to not be nomadic it allowed them to and
you could have probably had some hunters
who who were somewhat settled may be
living near the ocean maybe they did
some fishing and all the rest but for
the most part with the development of
Agriculture it forced people to stay in
one place so you have the Paleolithic
era all the way all the way to the
advent of Agriculture which was about
eleven thousand to seven thousand years
ago and besides the fact that it changed
people's diet it allowed them to settle
so agriculture agriculture allowed human
beings to settle down in one area and it
wasn't just that they were settling in
one area but because they were able to
control their environment they were able
to increase the density of things of of
crops that humans could consume in
animals that humans could consume and
lower the density of crops that humans
can't consume and that animals can't and
animals that they can't consume or they
they don't want around like you know
pests of some type what it allowed them
to do is also settle in more dense
environments you can imagine when you
just have people walking around you need
a lot of land to support even the
calorie requirements of one human being
but all of a sudden if you are able to
develop agriculture you're able to
domesticate animals all sudden you can
have in the same amount of land you can
have more calories being generated and
because you have more calories being
generated in a smaller amount of land
you can people can settle and they can
settle in a denser environment and so
agriculture was really this necessary
requirement for people to kind of
develop civilization or to develop
villages to develop villages and cities
and maybe also giving them for the free
time to start thinking about hey maybe
we want to think about how we can record
what we know how we can develop even
more technologies
and so just to give us a sense of the
the categorization that an archaeologist
would use for these different periods of
time I told you we start with the
Paleolithic era with the advent of stone
tools pre humans most of human time on
this planet and then about 11,000 years
ago the development of agriculture and
it developed independently at different
places around the world which is by
itself an interesting phenomenon and
people think that it might just be that
the the climate might have warmed up a
little bit so that people may be
naturally there were some some human
edible crops that existed in a little
bit of a denser environment and humans
learned to optimize that slowly and they
did that independently but it's an
interesting question of why did it
develop just then after a hundred and
you know 80 190 thousand years why did
agriculture all of a sudden happen but
just to get the terminology the
Paleolithic era is that period before
agriculture and then once agriculture
starts developing we are now in the
Neolithic we are now in the Neolithic
era and some archaeologists will
describe a transition period between the
Paleolithic and the Neolithic era called
the Mesolithic and just so you know what
these words mean because they actually
makes sense when you know what they mean
paleo paleo means old means old and
lithic means stone or of stone so
they're really talking about the Old
Stone Age Neolithic as you can imagine
means new new stone so it's kind of the
new Stone Age and meso means middle so
it is the middle it is the middle Stone
Age so another way of thinking about
this whole period from when people were
hunter-gatherers all the way to about
eleven eleven thousand to seven thousand
years ago and they develop agriculture
this whole period is called the Stone
Age and the Stone Age is kind of this
biggest age and there's just different
ways of describing it because if you
just call the Stone Age you're really
making importance out of the actual
tools that were people that that you
know that people could shape they
weren't able to use metal at this point
when you refer to Paleolithic and
Neolithic you're really you're maybe
referring a little bit more and there's
other ways to think about it but you're
referring a little bit more to the
lifestyles of the human beings
Paleolithic being hunter-gatherers
Neolithic
I have being actually settled having
actually started to develop a kind of
primitive villages and even cities and
then of course methyl Issyk methyl
lithium Mesolithic is in between and
just for kind of a pop-culture reference
you might have heard of the Paleolithic
diet that people some people are going
on now and those are people who try to
live like hunter-gatherers their belief
is that most of human evolution occurred
while we were hunter-gatherers and so
that's what our bodies are most
accustomed to so they like to eat meat
and they like to eat a lot of nuts and I
even met at a co-worker once who used to
only eat raw meat and I don't know if
that is even just a fighter that's even
somehow validated by the archaeological
record these people probably did cook
their meat now at the end of the Stone
Age we would have I would say the number
two most significant development in
human history and now we're talking
about 3000 BC which is about five
thousand years ago and this is the
development of writing so we were
hunter-gatherers about nine to ten
thousand eleven thousand years ago
people start developing agriculture
allows them to settle in more dense
environments it also gives them a little
bit more free time because they don't
have to hunt and gather all the time and
then you go and once again we'll
probably discover things as we go
forward in time that maybe these dates
need to be pushed back or whatever else
we discover new civilizations or who
knows but our best sense is you have
these villages you have these
civilizations developing and by about
five thousand years ago so this would be
five thousand before the present or
three thousand BC before Christ you have
people saying hey why don't we start
trying to write down what we know so it
doesn't so that you know when I tell
someone orally it doesn't actually lose
information there and that's our
descendants can slowly collect all of
the knowledge we have and maybe
accelerate you know I don't know if they
did it explicitly thinking of these but
let's just write down what we know and
so at about that period of time you have
as far as we can tell the first
development of kind of a pictogram based
system of writing and the earliest
system of writing we know is cuneiform
which is from the Sumerian civilization
which is now in
with present-day Iraq and what's the
really big deal about this is that this
is on some level the beginning of
recorded history we could talk about the
word history you could say the history
is all of the past and we could use the
arkla archaeological record to figure
out stuff before people started to write
things down but when they started to
write things down now it was recorded
now we're actually getting actual
accounts of what people know of actual
people's knowledge and the reason why
this is a big deal I mean agriculture
hopefully you now appreciate that that
it was a pretty big deal but the reason
why why writing was a big deal is that
now civilization could collect its
knowledge and it could it could build
upon it generation after generation
without having to worry about people
forgetting it or or information getting
distorted verbally from from from
ancestor to descendant and with that you
also have the beginning of the Bronze
Age and the Bronze Age is kind of known
for this beginning of even though it's
referring to a material which comes from
the first time that people started using
bronze as a tool or using bronze for
their tools and further weapons and
bronze just you know it's a mixture of
mostly copper and a little bit of tin
but the Bronze Age and at least in my
mind the biggest deal of what started at
the beginning of the Bronze Age really
really was the writing so once again
just as a review because I actually I
don't know I find this kind of confusing
most our current understanding most of
human prehistory and even pre human
prehistory we spent were spent as
hunter-gatherers using stone tools about
until about eleven thousand years ago
and then we became a little bit more
settled we became farmers essentially
using stone tools and then you fast
forward another about five six thousand
years and then we started to become
farmers who started to write down the
things that we knew and we started to
use bronze tools